and we just finished
30 days of yoga with adrian i'm adrienne
and i'm super excited
it's day one i've been doing yoga for
over a year now and started during the
pandemic
as i guess everybody but i never did a
full week of yoga
every day i always did max one day a
week
so doing this challenge i want to see
how much changes if one actually
practices
every single day and also see if i can
learn more on the background of yoga
[Music]
everything's fine
wouldn't expect any more from this
the situations in
[Music]
trying to appreciate and i
went trying to
evaluate
[Music]
was it something that i did
was it something that i couldn't quite
handle right
an invitation
[Music]
come a day
i'm gonna do some yoga with a friend
right now
and with charlie the dog so let's see
charlie the dog
[Music]
julie
[Music]
[Music]
look
[Music]
i don't know what it means but there's a
smile upon your face
and i see something shimmering in your
eyes
[Music]
and they say if you wanna glimpse the
future you need space
and you said you put down your morning
guns
would you follow me to wonder
imposter
when you look at me this way
[Music]
i find it hard to not
give in
so i'm currently in my kitchen again
on my yoga bed and i kind of figured a
friend of mine
gave me this book this one that you see
here
um which has all the ashtanga poses
that one can do so it starts off by
these really simple poses
um with also an explanation on how to
breathe
where to put your focus and everything
and it ends these kind of
super crazy poses so i kind of just
figured i would
go through them and see how many
i can do so that's what i'm gonna do
right now
[Music]
it makes you feel a little stronger
[Music]
who knows what you may find you'll see
it in your own time it might just take a
little longer
it all goes by so slowly
you waited your whole life your day's
turning tonight
okay so now we're going to
really advance poses so i'm not really
sure
what the [ __ ] the
toy toys
[Music]
okay let's try
[Music]
it all goes by so slowly
you waited your whole life your day's
turning tonight
so i think from day four onwards i
really started to notice the benefits of
practicing every single day
i felt more relaxed and my body was more
flexible than ever
furthermore learning about the
philosophy behind asanas
also allowed me to really focus during
the day and being more kind
and compassionate so i think this week
has not only benefited
my body but mainly my mind
[Music]
[Music]
it all goes by so slowly
you waited your whole life your day's
turning tonight
[Music]
going to another yoga class right now
it's
something called like dance flow i think
it will be good
because it's a little bit more dance
moves involved and i
used to do dance so i think for me that
will be a little bit easier than the
super hardcore yoga i also did this
morning the
class with cassandra and i quite like
her flow
although the only thing i notice is when
i try to do yoga at home
i really notice how hard it is for me to
focus i guess because my living space is
actually extremely small it's basically
just one
one room so for me to do yoga in my own
living space
i get distracted really easily and start
to for example
eat something or clean up my house so
yeah i think these
lessons for me work a little bit better
but i would love to
have it in my routine as well to be able
to do
yoga for example in the morning always
or before i go to bed
so hopefully by the end of this
challenge i will have
figured out some kind of schedule that
works a little bit better
with my routine but we'll see
today at morgan's rock eco lodge and we
just
finished completing our boat
so yeah today is day six of the yoga
challenge
and i've been doing pretty good so far
um but i kind of wanted to challenge
myself today because it's
saturday so i kind of figured i could do
a little bit
more so i wanted to try to do the
inversions of yoga so the headstand
crow what else do you have well anyways
so i'm gonna do a few tutorials to see
how one
actually does it um and i can do a
handstand against the wall but i cannot
do it
without a wall so i'm probably gonna
hurt myself
[Music]
[Applause]
another week another day another
hour since you went away and so cliche
you didn't say goodbye
so i have been wanting to incorporate
yoga in my evening routine for
quite some time like do a few little
stretches and just
really relax and meditate before i go to
bed
um so yeah i'm gonna try to do that now
i found quite a nice one from
sandra for flexibility and relaxation
and that's something we all want i guess
so we'll see
if i can finish these 15 minutes without
walking away and
[Music]
with all these things i'm going through
i still wish the best for you you're not
the only one to love
there's plenty more under the sun you'll
find the one you need
reach your total fantasy
[Music]
i still wish the best for you you're not
the only one alone
there's plenty more under the sun you'll
find the one you need
reach your total fantasy
[Music]
[Applause]
i have found my reasons now
[Music]
to keep my burdens left behind
i did not know what it would bring
now i'm capable of everything
[Music]
so these seven days have really showed
me the benefits of a daily practice
even on days you are busy a tiny 15
minutes of just sitting on your mouth
and breathing can really help make you
more present
i hope i can keep some of the skills i
learn in my routine for the following
year
and i hope some of you will join me as
well on this journey
see you at the next challenge
[Music]
that i'm bye of everything